good morning John I don't know if you've
heard about this yet but there's a hip
new challenge going on on YouTube right
now and I'm super interested in it it's
called Lee explained the 2008 financial
crisis in less than 60 seconds challenge
so I'm gonna try to do interest rates in
2008 were super low which meant that
banks could basically borrow money for
free so they had tons of potential money
but they needed stuff to buy and the
most important new thing to buy turned
out to be people's mortgages because
they were more than 13 trillion dollars
of them therefore institutions that are
important to this story lenders who made
the loan investment banks who bought
packaged and resold the loan ratings
agencies who told investors how risky
the loans were and investors who bought
the loans from the banks because of this
new system a bunch of people did a bunch
of things that they should not have done
anders didn't need to worry about
whether the loans would be paid off
anymore because they were just selling
the loans on because there was so much
demand they started to create
manipulative loans that they gave to
people who could never pay them on those
subprime loans were purchased by
investment banks who did a number of
duplicitous things to make rating
agencies think that they were not
subprime loans they were rated as
triple-a and investors bought them
thinking that they were getting a good
thing and eventually when the inevitable
happened and people couldn't pay off
their loans the entire House of Lies
came crashing down along with a good
portion of the global economy challenge
complete and now I got like three
minutes left of this video so I should
do some more challenges there's a bunch
of good ones that grow a bunch of hair
challenge each of my 150,000 hair
follicles produces around 0.44
millimeters of hair per day meaning that
in total I grow around 0.2 9 inches of
hair per second over the course of a day
if all of my hair growth were
concentrated on one hair that hair would
be 220 feet long so while you can't see
hair grow you do grow a lot of it to try
to make a harpsichord noise challenge
swing gang getting gangbanged I'm going
to ding ding dong took a dig ding dong
time drink however much mouthwash you
have left challenge I should have bought
a smaller bottle huh the challenge
though
just water with food coloring in it come
all the make breakfast on snapchat
challenge the how loud can you scream
challenge we apologize for something
while you're doing it challenge I don't
dislike challenge videos I actually
quite like them I think they're fun and
I think it's difficult to come up with
good ideas for challenges and to have a
good time and read it together good
challenge videos I want this video to be
seen as mocking challenge videos but
instead rethinking that genre to fit my
own aesthetically have a jump cut in
evidence of this challenge and finally
the how far up your body can you bite
challenge huh yeah I wish count you're
like our arm arm Oh John I'll see you on
Tuesday only a week until the project
for awesome starts this day next week it
will begin there will be a live stream
it will be great and fun you should join
us put aside a little bit of your
schedule if you want to make a video
that people can vote on and your
favorite charity might get a whole bunch
of money you can do that and maybe put a
little bit of your money aside too
because there's gonna be a bunch of
really cool perks
ah dude dude dude